これじゃあ外れ社長ねどうやろしかの方
照明が明るいので撮影せるエアーここから動いてこっち
はいというわけでここに撮影してるんですけども
結局こういう少年ってなんかあの撮影用じゃないで川倉ってなっちゃうよどうしても
なんでまだちょっと表情をよくするためにこういう証明等を張っててるんですぞ地下に
行くとそういう必要もなくなっちゃうんですよ金積んで改造したんで明るいんですよ
ゆ食べもうなんか撮影とかデブしたで行ったほうが絶対 in the
ないかなと思いましていろいろ荷物とかあるんですけども全部まとめて地下において
しかも3 p スタ中にしようと思いますではいがー
よ
[音楽]
ん
たかっホップっ意志ある医者にねこの子
[音楽]
んん
me
tan
ああああああ
あああっはああああああああっ
ぐうっ
[音楽]
ん
4日
ええええええ
ええええええええええええ
ああああああん
[音楽]
[笑い]
というわけでし印刷を過去軽いああっ
そう綺麗なはいと言うしかということなんですけども
照明は完璧ですめっちゃ見やすいんですけどもはというかものが少なすぎで声が響き
ますね
もうちょっとちょっとものであふれ変えるさせたいぐらいに下津井です
というわけで広いのでも重い損損遊べます
オーダーできますじゃあし続けて完成しましたこれはもともとあったんです
けどももう広さが全然違いますねもう縦横無尽に移動できるんで超楽なんですけども
こんな空間でどうぞと良いかと思いますバッチリエアコンもありますし
骨やミスいいどうもありますで上を見たいなにょれ上からでも道が取れそうな気がし
ますねこれ
というわけでまあそろそろ引っ越しかなっていつもの
なんか東京でいい物件が見つからなくてですねもうちょっとは確定で静岡にいると思い
ますので暫くはこの部屋で頑張って行きたいと思いますでもなんかすごい
遊び放題っぽい気がするんで恋響くなだけちょっとやですね
もうちょっとものを増やしたいと思いますではまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃん
うっうーで
b